we begin this morning with president
Trump's renewed warning to illegal
immigrants and asylum seekers who were
trying to cross into the u.s. from
Mexico on Friday mr. Trump visited the
border town of Calexico California where
he told them to turn around adding quote
our country is full he is also putting
Mexico on notice threatening economic
penalties if it does not stop the
illegal crossings this comes after he
backed down from closing the southern
border entirely after facing strong
criticism from within his own party
Errol Barnett is at the White House with
the latest Darrel good morning good
morning weeks after declaring a national
emergency at the southern border
President Trump has ratcheted up his
immigration rhetoric eager to show the
press the first completed sections of
the southern border wall president Trump
has increased his attacks on migrants
from Central America and the president
is threatening Mexico with dire economic
consequences if it doesn't do more to
help well we're gonna shut it down if we
have to what Mexico can do it very
easily and surrounded by Republican
lawmakers and Border Patrol agents
president Trump retreated from his
threat to shut down the entire southern
border we're gonna shut it down if we
have to we're gonna tear off the cars
coming in if they make it Mexico if we
have two Border Patrol officers said the
newly renovated wall has already helped
them in these two miles just illegal
entries alone have dropped by 75 percent
at a roundtable on border security the
president went as far as declaring
asylum seekers a hoax the system is full
can't take you anymore asylum you know I
look at some of these Asylum people they
gang members they're not afraid of
anything they have lawyers greeting them
they read what the lawyer tells them to
read the gang members and they say I
fear for my life and all of a sudden
Mexico is doing terrifically while the
president denied he changed his mind
about shutting down the border Friday
this was his vow just last week I'm
telling you right now we will close the
damn border
we'll keep it closed for a long time I'm
not playing games the reversal comes
after warnings from leaders within the
GOP closing down the border would have
potentially catastrophic economic impact
on our country in California the
president also laid out plans to
complete his wall once and for all and
we expect to have close to 400 miles
done within about two years from now
that's a lot most of it now California
is leading a group of more than 20
states asking a federal judge to stop
President Trump from diverting federal
funds to build this southern border wall
they call this unconstitutional and they
say to construct a wall under these
circumstances would cause them
irreparable damage Michelle
all right Errol thank you